salut mais c'est tout de l'est qu'est-ce
que vous soyez capable de donner par
amour tiens natacha xoom seriez capable
de donner par amour bonsoir déjà merci
d'être là ce soir
par amour par amour je suis capable de
donner bas de donner ma vie c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
dieu bénisse en rigolait vous la pension
alimentaire
[Applaudissements]
vous verrez que la vie s'arrête ici
gilbert vous salle en moins je mens je
peux donner par amour je serais même
capable de l'année ont permis de
conduire permet d'allumer mon corps non
[Musique]
sauvé benhaim elle c'est une chaudière à
cronat sur la vie de ma mère c'est un
grille pain
as-tu mais le taux se dedans et ressorts
et les grilles ici alors je vais vous
dire la ja il ya un parfum deux noms
laponie ya un problème laponie avec la
laponie
ça commence à son talent et gilles buna
il ses sens sont en éveil
farrell historique quand benhalima les
sens en éveil il faut pas rester à côté
parce que elle peut pécho nom porte
plutôt quoi un bénin où vous seriez
capable donné quoi pas mais les airs en
veux tu en voilà
versus c'est bon c'est bon christine
tiens moi ma paye ah ouais pas donné à
tout de suite à berne
comment vous m'avez bien oui bah alors
d'amitié volvo trucks l'amitié
alors tu ne sais pas quoi en amitié je
passerai ma attention l'amitié entre
attention la flamme tiers surtout sur
l'argent et matthieu delormeau et en
peignoir on va vous expliquer pourquoi
dans la sauce qui effectivement j'avais
demandé
j'adore exceptionnel c break et mathieu
jaton peignoir parce que vous avez gagné
votre billet pour la laponie dans un
instant c'est ce soir ou jamais je suis
pas là demain en plus voilà mais c'est
où vous caroline ithurbide way home
adagio 10e tout le monde serait bien
vous savez caroline ce serait mieux pour
jean michel vous ça serait mieux pour
michel lasbats président de la pologne
un des fans qui m'attendent et j'adore
car home je crois pas qu'elle ait fana
bataille ne croyait vraiment qu'il ya
des fans avant qui centrale ce joli en
laponie et oui ça tu arraches un oui ça
m'a retenu est ce que vous feriez par
amour vous qu'est ce que je pourrais
donner mon conjoint
si vous aussi vous réfugiez c'est très
beau je lui offre la possibilité d'aller
voir ailleurs non c'est beau c'est beau
ça vous fait exactement ce que fait le
mari d'irene
qu'est ce que vous donnez vous par amour
tout le reste sauf la vie justement et
notamment du temps parce que les gens
quand il tend au zoo ouais c'était
marrant je leur donne ses chiens juste
le reste en même temps vous donnez du
temps jusqu'aux personnes le voeu n'a
pas s'il est magnifique et qu'est ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure je dis je
des junies tuer des choses a promis
turbide et la merci alors ils viivent on
part il va pas rester car oui nadia
juste pour le jeune henry c'est mon rêve
d'enfant ça vacallo ma place ça très
bien merci d'être là bas n'est alors pas
de galanterie un joli des maires ruraux
coup vous coller mais qu'est ce que vous
seriez capable de donner moi je ne sais
pas je dirais ok pour une expérience
totalement inédite un truc que j'ai
jamais fait c'est à dire vous que je me
suis toujours refusé à faire
elle va partir en laponie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la survie des belles chansons chacun
apportant la police oui et donc voilà
c'est ça fait un truc nouveau auquel me
voue pas clair selon qu il y aura d
autres réduire dans la vie et même la
neige elle bafoue la barre a menacé un
nom mais lui c'est un feu de bois les
gars ça il faut mettre des pizzas sur
ses idées voyez vous moi tout faire pour
que la personne soit heureuse que c'est
[Musique]
là c'est vraiment là c'est la réponse du
gars de tf1 vidéo de faire le bouffon
bah si c'est le seul intérêt nu et
delphine dîner chiant alors tel père
telle fille delphine alors afin de se
calmer avec delphine sur itunes
valissant d'autres 4 5 étages avec
delphine c'est vrai fait partie
maintenant de mes meilleurs amis
donc pourquoi je vous dis final fait
partie de mes quatre cinq meilleurs amis
du coup sûr c'est qu'ils les autres des
films alors qu'est-ce que je donne par
amour en moi je suis à mi chemin entre
la fusion et la liberté
ce que je suis pas quelqu'un de jalouser
en revanche j'ai besoin de fusion et
connexions que la personne donc du coup
je pense que ça c'est pas mal la fusion
sabia a même la fusion est même plus les
jeunes est comme les boîtes qui
fusionnent et connecté tout le temps et
puis en même temps tu laisses la
personne super league pass ya rien de
pire que la jalousie quand est on va
dire que pendant vous allez partir
quatre jours en laponie rouge il va
pouvoir le faire mais déjà il va pouvoir
il va pouvoir bosser parce qu'il est un
super projet va merci roger ranger qui
l'a eu
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est moi même qui t'appellerai tous
les jours pour te donner des nouvelles
ça fait plaisir vous savez qu'un
téléphone il faut l'appeler oui mais bon
je peux l'appeler moi même je le fais
moi-même c'est plus prudent
voulez vous qu est ce que vous serez
après donnez votre camion non je ne
pense donc à main mais je suis pas un
menu buffalo le magnet du shérif
j'emmène bonsoir cyril hanouna ouais
ouais alors tu attends moi par amour ben
je pense que dieu donne de l'amour c'est
déjà énorme donc on se contente de ce
qu'on a dit bah déjà le mec mahut est
contente elle va redescendre de cinq
étages la miss monde par des sons d'la
vous vous ai donné beaucoup votent non
non mon coeur et mon âme pour que la
force vitale de facto soit décuplée par
sonia veut dire là et bien derrière
vient de me dire ça y est je me suis
barré
[Rires]